JUSTIN BECKWITH: With almost
500 sessions in Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see "Preventing
the Next Major Security
Breach," then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No matter if your
company is big or small,
when it comes to
security, everyone
asks the same question--
am I secure enough?
While it's easy to
focus on the technology
side of this question,
the pros know the truth.
Security is a business problem.
It comes down to trust and
balancing financial trade-offs.
There's also no perfect solution
to securing your business.
And if someone tries to
sell you one, watch out.
Instead, security prevention is
about addressing known factors
and tackling the most
frequent root causes--
known vulnerabilities
and container handling.
Thinking about
vulnerabilities, there
are three primary places to
protect yourself-- code time,
build time, and deploy time.
All three cases benefit
from better processes
around handling your
code to reduce risk.
This is fundamentally
a process problem,
and your software
lifecycle can be
made safer with better process.
At code time, you
need a process to test
your third-party
libraries and tools
so you know you're integrating
safe code from the outside.
At build time, you
need to address
issues in your operating
system and included packages
so you don't expose yourself
to a vulnerability based
on your platform.
And at deploy time,
you need good ways
to ensure you're actually
deploying the right binary
so nobody can sneak in an
alternate dangerous version
without your knowledge.
Luckily, Google has
some ways to make
all of this easier for you.
Let's start with the Container
Registry Vulnerability Scanner,
which can examine your
containers before you deploy,
checking for any
known vulnerabilities
so you can patch your
update before sending
something unsafe out there.
To keep your containers
safe once they're deployed,
it's key to install updates
and upgrades regularly--
preferably each day.
And remove packages you
don't need to further reduce
your exposure.
If possible, go find a smaller
OS distribution to even further
shrink your attack surface.
Thankfully, that doesn't have
to be a manual process, adding
to your existing toil.
We've got tools to help you
with integration and deployment
processes to improve security,
baking in scans and tests
to analyze what
you're deploying.
And we'll notify you when any
new vulnerability is discovered
that affects your
code, via email,
web notifications, mobile
app, Pub/Sub, or API calls.
Now, on the open source
side, the Grafeas project
can help with your
security needs
by establishing a
consistent API for vendors
to define what artifacts
exist in a build system,
what vulnerabilities
might be present,
and what you can audit
throughout your lifecycle.
Google's container analysis
API implements Grafeas,
and many other
companies have partnered
to strengthen this standard.
What if you're using
Kubernetes already
and want to take advantage
of this vulnerability data?
The Kubernetes
Admission Controller
can sit between your code and
your Kubernetes environment,
intercepting requests
to the API and checking
the safety of the containers
before they're run.
If you want to see it
in action, check out
Kelsey Hightower's demo linked
in the description below.
Already we're making
good security progress,
but let's take it further.
What if you want to test
assertions before deploying
containers in your cluster?
Kritis, another open
source project we support,
enables you to prove build
provenance and require scanning
before container deployment.
Security is hard,
and we want to help.
Google Cloud has many tools to
help you secure your software
deployment process,
and we're working
closely with partners
across the space, openly
and collaboratively.
Thanks for watching.
You can see the full talk
link in the description below.
Subscribe to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more Next Rewind
videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]